salut à tous c'est envergure et c'est
bientôt les fêtes alors on sort le
champagne
voilà julian champagny c'est le podcast
du soir c'est la mauvaise blague
d'entrée ses entrées mais comme ça elle
est faite tu vois ce que je veux dire
c'est notre thème du jour ils jouent à
saint john le frère de justin champagne
qui évolue aux raptors il fait un bon
début de saison du lait est en panne il
est grand il shoote donc c'est un
candidat naturel pour la drague 2022 qui
sera analysé le jeu de justin de julian
champagne y sera analysé par nono
destiny's childs à nous nico hugues alan
comment allez vous
salut tout le monde savait pas légion
est-ce que julien et créole
parce que là with it all away ok
ça commence très très fort c'est fait
je voulais avant de lancer le générique
vous demander si vous buviez le
champagne avant ou après le repas
après
la presse est unanime
[Musique]
mais après annie sinon champagne avant
et le rhum
exactement voilà les donc ça sera
peut-être un thème à développer pour
notre ami jb hacker poster dunk qui a
lancé distiller son podcast sur
les vins et spiritueux donc avec
julien de champagny avant ou après le
repas c'est le générique ses revers
[Musique]
allez julian chang panique qui est ce
monsieur a par le frère de justin qui
évolue aux raptors hughes va nous dire
son histoire et pour compléter si vous
avez l'occasion vous invite à aller voir
sa fiche à julian champagne et 1d x 1000
3000 joueurs au moins en avoir une sur
notre site envergure penser aux avec
photo statuant sur actions ic cetera
hugues l'histoire de julian s'il te
plaît
c'est battre jeudi anne champagne et
comme tu l'as dit le frère de justin
chang pagny il a il est né dans à
brooklyn new york
il a fait là-bas son lycée du coup avec
son avec son frère papa sportif papa
c'est le thème un peu de la soirée qui a
joué au football donc soccer pour st
john's university dans les années 90 et
qui a fait gagner justement le titre en
95 avec eux
julian il est assez assez prisé il va
choisir de ne pas rejoindre son frère à
pittsburgh mais d'aller à la maison
saint john's là et les juniors 3e année
c'est le leader de son équipe et c'est
une des stars de scoring l'histoire tout
court delesne trier
qui ils évoluent hugues dans une équipe
plutôt performant dans une conférence
plutôt performante mais pas dans une
grande équipe d'une grande conférence si
je peux résumer ouest et sol et je dois
la dent l'habite liste donc qui est
aussi fait partie des ae mesure donc des
six plus grosses conférences cndd jeunes
c'est une équipe qui commence pas très
très bien il ya des programmes plus
référencés comme villanova comme yukon
comme profit de ces dernières années
ouais c'est ça
donc l'histoire de juliette champagny
place à aux cordes et julian champagne
que nous dit son corps que nous dit le
ce qu'on peut imaginer d'un prospect
canton juste on le regarde évoluer sur
un terrain et quand on regarde ses
mensurations aussi nico qu'est ce que ça
dit du côté de julian et ben
sans panis et 6,8 donc ces deux matches
0 3 cg robot avait 6
avec une envergure de 2,08 donc il est
né en juin 2001
ont pour moi aujourd'hui c'est très bien
c'est il ya les épaules c'est costaud
pour moi il ya tout pour faire un vrai
corps de buffle il ya tout pour pour
vraiment rajouter
les deltoïdes
tout ce qu'il faut pour pouvoir se faire
une place dans la raquette et plus si
affinités
visuellement parfois quand il quand il
quand il se déplace je trouve qu'il ya
un air de maïs bridge physiquement elle
va pas dans le jeu ok je parle je parle
vraiment dans le physique pas uniquement
à cause de la barbe
voilà ce que moi ce qui me saute aux
yeux c'est la densité c'est à dire que
j'ai pas son poids d'ailleurs 1 600 kg
jeu ce qui m'a paru assez souvent parce
que il avait l'air un peu plus lourd sur
le terrain mais mais voilà un joueur qui
est qui et tanks et physiquement qui qui
on parlait lors du pape hot de précède
un précédent de akbar j autant akbar j a
une capacité à se déplacer
évidente autant champagne il ne brille
pas par par la vitesse de ces
changements de direction
c'est un peu plus
pour moi c'est un peu plus profil et 3,4
que de 3 alors j'espère que mes
collègues vont pas me jeter de pierres à
cause de ça mais mais mais je trouve
qu'il a il a tout du corps du joueur qui
va finir par se rapprocher de la
raquette parce que il n'a pas la
latéralité pour défendre sur des plus
petits ouais ouais et ses skis si
ressortait au combat une aussi l'année
dernière en niveau de la lane agility
times donc c'est le le
comment dire l'exercice qui font où ils
doivent aller toucher déconne
et faire des diagonales etc il avait le
deuxième plus mauvais temps
derrière des grilles et luc portet lucas
garza et j'en passe ah oui quand même
derrière l'intérieur et grandes écoles
ouais ouais derrière chicago ça donc
donc voilà alors peut-être qu'ils
n'étaient pas dans un bon jour aussi
c'est un peu le truc de celle de céline
agility mais en tout cas voilà il passe
pas un athlète si on peut résumer à
l'âne c'est quoi son à son attrait pour
l'alaska au tnba qu'elles la traitent
jeune julian sean penn sont chers
stratfor
voilà c'était une très belle émission et
tout était dit bonne soit
la créateur d'espacés un floor spacer's
des américains lors qu'il va jouer post
4 je pense pas une bille et
offensivement que défensivement pour
avoir ce qui peut défendre mais
offensivement voilà comme l'a dit nico
je suis assez d'accord
sur son manque de vivacité sont donc je
pense que la carte d'entrée c'est un un
spécialiste spécialiste du tir je pense
sachant qu on y reviendra plus tard mais
il est plutôt efficace au cercle
des coupes et où le but d'avoir le
terrain de billets c'est que fait pas
même quand il ya plus d'espacé donc
lorsque ça peut aider si ça
alors justement on va passer aux
questions donc on a eu la cale à la
carte d'identité de notre ami julian
chang panique est terminée j'ai donc
regardé quelques extraits et je me pose
des questions quand je regarde aussi les
stats
et je vois un rebondeur extrêmement
impressionnant quand on regarde les
stats avancé vous êtes peut-être pas
sauté aux yeux mais
j'ai lu un article là dessus
je vous donnerai les stades plus tard
mais bref les stats avancées disent
qu'il est extrêmement bon rebondeur
défensif mais c'est vraiment plaisir
parce que ses qualités premières de
noter tirer le deuxième j'ai mis
présence au rebond donc je suis contente
et ben écoute et gelé ma question étant
est ce que c'est important en fait est
ce que c'est important à quel point
c'est important
pour sa projection en vie et bien après
je laisserais jeu là je parle trop
désolé mais pour moi justement cette ses
stats c'est un trompe l'oeil parce que
aujourd'hui il défend sur
l'île et on va dire en duel avec des
joueurs qui sont plus profilé 2,3 et du
coup c'est normal qu'ils dominent parce
qu'il est plus long parce qu'il est plus
costaud mais ce que je mettais à côté de
son deuxième point fort c'est que
arriver à une bille et pour moi cette
deuxième fois fort il n'existera plus ok
très bien hughes et allen est ce que ça
vous paraît important est ce que vous
regardez le les chiffres de rebond ou
alors les stats avant serbe ont contesté
et cetera con quand vous regardez un
joueur universitaire
pense que c'est important parce que moi
je le projet comme un
3/4 plus tourné vers le cadre donc pense
qu'il faudrait qu'ils l'aient deux
rebonds défensifs
je pense qu'ils ça c'est pas l'euro
c'est pas le joueur comme tu veux comme
l'a pu dire peut-être nico c'est pas le
joueur qui a
quasiment telle critique quasiment à 20
% de rebond défensif l'an dernier où un
joueur qui était un joueur quitté voilà
primordial dans le le jeu de son jeu de
rebond de son équipe mais en même temps
je pense que son poids sa longueur sa
hauteur pendant vont faire que de facto
il aura un rôle sur le rebond défensif
donc pour moi c'est pas accès un plus ou
un moins c'est que là où je le projette
en tant que stretch 4 ça va être
nécessaire pour déjà que parce que cet
aspect défensif c'est un peu complexe
que moi ça va être nécessaire qu'il est
décrit une présence ou robots donc je
trouve ça bien
hugues est ce que tu confirme ce que dit
nico sur l'ailé le fait qu'il ait quand
même affronté en majorité des joueurs
qu'il domine physiquement et que donc
des stats au rebond même si c'est des
rebonds contester ces contestée par des
joueurs on va dire que je suis
totalement d'accord là dessus il a
dominé on aime beaucoup de mannequins
qui domine au n 6 a parce qu'ils sont
plus prêts physiquement et qui sont très
intelligent mais qu'il n'a pas un
physique d'athlète nba et comme le
dialogue c'est pour moi un poste qui va
se faire du stretch retraite cat pardon
et que s'ils prenaient pas de rebond
enfin je ne resterai pas tout court ce
gars là est ce qu'il ya vraiment un gros
problème de latéralité voilà maintenant
ils compensent et je pense que c'est
peut-être moi les ailes et s'explique
elle exprime sa qu'il a un très très bon
qi basket défensif et un très bon qui
masque est tout court qui est tout le
temps très très bien placé votre ami
tchang pagny et donc il sait me permets
de te prendre des rebonds là où les
autres y sont pas parce que lui voit où
va arriver la balle ça lui permet d'être
dans l'aide ça lui permet d'être dans
l'interception dans le contracte à terra
alors que c'est pas du tout un athlète
oui il a des stats plutôt
très acceptable très honorable quand on
parle de deux contres d'interception et
c'est effectivement
j'ai regardé donc on vous parle de son
tir sont son point fort
on peut voir un peu de variété
j'ai vu des tirs où il sortait d'un
petit sprint en style heures
mais dans l'ensemble ils les plantes
quand même souvent ses pieds c'est à
dire qu'il a besoin de faire un petit un
petit up ou alors il a besoin de ramener
son je crois que carmen le pied gauche
après il fait droite gauche
sur sur ses shoots en catch and shoot
donc est-ce qu'il peut devenir un joueur
qui met des tirs vraiment difficile en
catch and shoot donc spécialistes à la
manière de duncan robinson dont on dut
souhaitent de sortir de son seul m
duncan ou bien est-ce qu'il a d'autres
cordes à son arc pour exister en nba je
parlais tout à l'heure tu sa capacité à
finir près du cercle quand même
assez assez fascinante pour un joueur
qui est pas un athlète elle problème
c'est qu'ils courent pas comme duncan
robinson le fait qui peut pas on ne peut
pas faire des courses comme robinson le
fait ça va vraiment être petite chienne
pop pick and pop hip hop et pour le coup
là dessus cependant avec un défenseur
qui lui met la main à nouveau les yeux
il prend son tir il a pas peur c'est un
joueur qui qui vivent très bien sous la
pression qui peut mettre des gros tirs
avec
trop de confiance en lui mais je le vois
pas faire des courses c'est vraiment un
jour de pick and roll hockey parce que
c'est vrai qu'après sur les quatre
jeunes toute fin en règle générale il
est à
37 % carrière sur quasiment sur quatre
tentatives et demi et cette année 41 %
et a que huit matches mais 41% sur cette
tentative à trois points vraiment un
très bon shooteur à trois points l'année
dernière était très bons lancers francs
là il n'a pas très bien démarré mais ça
viendra sans doute puisqu'il en prend
pas beaucoup en plus nico est ce que est
ce que tu le vois avoir une diversité de
tir suffisante pour se faire une place
dans un roster end
malheureusement n'ont pour l'instant
parce que alors même si la balle est
très haute sur sa réalise la trajectoire
du hockey n'est pas le papa n'est pas de
nowitzki est
mais en fait pour moi la préparer en
trois temps là où les gros shooteur vont
avoir va avoir de temps réception tire
lui il y a
le moment où il remonte pour ensuite on
va dire ce bloc au niveau du coude ce
temps là en nba il l'aura il leur
apparaît donc du coup
bah moi je vois là je me pose des
questions je me pose des questions par
rapport à ça en sachant que comme tu
l'as dit effectivement il a dit il à des
pourcentages qui sont vraiment bons
autour du autour du panier mais il ya on
va pas le mettre sur le terrain pour ça
donc du coup il va falloir quand même
qu'il quillan plante
[Musique]
après le dribble j'en ai pas vu beaucoup
je suis pas sûr une grosse un gros
nombre de matchs pour lui j'ai un peu
galéré pour voir ces matches 82 % de ces
tirs à trois points sont pris en quatre
petites années bon ben voilà et comme tu
le disais effectivement
les pieds dans le ciment après bon ici
tu peux te dire effet de 0,3 ok mais là
bas les hôtes d'accord mais moi j'ai un
gros doute sur le pilot volume le fait
que ça soit là sinon comment dire le
score numéro un le go to hell de son
équipe est-ce qui est ce qu'il va être
capable d'être performant en peu de
temps de jeu voilà ça fait moi je trouve
que ça fait plein de l'interrogation
pour lui alan je n'ai pas entendu sur
sur le
le niveau du shooteur qui pourrait
éventuellement devenir
notre ami julien de champagne et est ce
que te des comparaisons qui paraissent
viable
c'est sûr qu'on n'aurait pas dit de quel
robinson c'est faux c'est difficile de
comparer avec eux ce qui fait quasiment
de mieux en fait voilà dans le rôle mais
à moi si si si ça devient je sais pas
comment d'alain s'utiliser maxi kléber
où si ça devient comment accepter par
les plus grands mais si ça devient ce
genre de profil là ça me va très bien en
fait ça me va très bien et ça peut je
peux je peux y penser dès la trentième
place parce que je trouve que avoir un
spécialiste qu'on va faire travailler
qu'on va jusque là voilà moi je il fait
déjà quasiment beaucoup de shoots mais
en lui demandant fait de faire un peu
d'autres choses dit il et ça n'est rien
11% des deux passes décisives ces taux
d'usagé très haut il va plus sereine que
chaque bagis d'ailleurs par exemple ce
qu'est ce qui prouve que dans les
cendres il n'est pas exceptionnel non
plus parce qu'il prouve que dans les
coupes ou les choses comme ça il a un
rôle intéressant moi je pense qu'il faut
le prendre le modelé voir que depuis
cours des deux dernières années sur
quasiment 40 35 matches on a un joueur
qui a 40 et 40 % à 3 points sur 6,5 en
natif par match et lui et faire bosser
ça voilà moi j'ai la confiance sur le
tir je pense que c'est un bon shooteur
la variété est pas incroyable mais pour
un joueur qui va être mon septième
huitième homme m je pense pas une
incroyable variété le plafond n'est pas
très haut mais le plancher par son
adresse je pense est assez intéressant
et ce qui peut faire une passe que nico
parlais tout à l'heure du fait qu'ils
aient de la place pour mettre encore
plus de muscle et du complice une sorte
de buffle pour un peu compenser ça
manque de latéralité ce qui peut faire
une sorte de jack krauser inversé c'est
à dire est d'abord bon tir et devenir
correct en défense
des grandeurs c'est le modèle à suivre
pour tous les joueurs qui sont ici et
qui ont soit pas le corps et mais qui
ont le foot soit nos joues tu n'es pas
d'accord et qui vont par une pour
devenir le sujet andy quasiment intime
parce que tu as dit est un terme un peu
galvaudé thomson n'est pas fini il pose
le ballon au sol et sa wii et
condottiere près des des trois points
sur le panier mais de tête brodeur c'est
vraiment le meilleur meilleur scénario
mais jack rodwell à une vitesse de pieds
bien plus intéressante jean pâli était
qu un klose a ôté que vous faites le
mais qu'il fait pas un tir et qu'à part
en dribble il est dans le vent donc
jamais ils sont quand même et pas
d'autres il prend quand même pas d'autre
type 2/3 crowder la vitesse de bras au
filet mais il va pas au cercle il prend
pas de mes distances donc en réalité
savoie une mère grand chose vous aimez
sa souveraineté alors que la champagne
ce sera un
twibbon sera sera lui aussi
d'être gaullistes collectif tu vois mais
parce qu'il est en fait on y voit là
mais il y défendra jamais en nba faut
comprendre que ce sera toujours un point
de mort défensif dans son équipe mais je
parlais du fait qu offensivement on vous
retrouve qu'on a tendance parfois sur
côté la variété d des rôles pour le
payeur parce que les gens
il va prendre je pense olivier les trois
quarts de ces tirs à trois points je
pense ou plus de 50% nico tu voulais
prendre la parole ou pas non non je
peut-être juste rééquilibrer ça qu'on
est en train de déboîter défensivement
il est pas si dégueulasse que ça c'est
juste que encore une fois pour moi il
défend sur des sur des joueurs qui sont
qui correspondent pas à sa position et à
son corps
mais justement si défend sur des joueurs
déjà un peu plus l'an mil sera sera une
bille est donc ils seront pas forcément
plus lent mais jay crowder pour moi
c'est pas une vitesse de pieds
extraordinaire pour contraire ce que
dieu mais parfois juste son corps il est
tellement gros que
le l'attaquant peut pas vraiment passé à
côté quoi et donc ça laisse un peu plus
de temps peut-être les le dixième de
secondes supplémentaires à cruiser pour
bouger son pied et les réorienter en
fait c'est là où on est limités dans nos
projections s'il faudrait qu'on sache
est-ce que ce mec là est un bosseur
est-ce que ce mec-là la capacité de 2
de passer ses étés à travailler là
dessus et si un peu la limite aussi de
nos projections encore une fois si ce
mec là il arrive avec les épaules de
cruiser et qu'il est capable d'améliorer
ne serait ce que 2 5%
savate et khalid et
on pourra dire oui bah oui ok il va on
peut le mettre sur un terrain à des
moments clés parce que il va être
capable de
de stretch la défense et de pas être un
trou d'air de l'autre côté georges
justement est ce qu il est bosseur ou
pas est-ce qu'on a des
retours sur son des retours des
estimations sur son implication
dans son travail dans son nom ce qui
peut devenir son métier et puis sur sa
psychologie en règle générale ce qui est
sûr d ' ce qui n'a pas empêché d'aller à
la draft comme son jumeau ça après c'est
très compliqué de connaître parce qu'on
n'a pas les entrées dans tous les
programmes initiés on nous dit ce qu'on
veut nous dire mais moi je trouve ça
courageux de sa part après les tests
physiques qu'il a fait et peut-être que
les retours de certains scouts de dire
bon bah je vais revenir aux initiés et
puis et puis avoir une progression
d'année en année il aurait pu peut-être
moi j'ai toujours préféré giuliana
justin très honnêtement
justin comprends pas qu'on utilisait un
to hell sur justin champagne
mais il a fait un très bon été justement
en se montrant intelligent en somme et
en ligue il me semble qu'ils étaient
plutôt contents les raptors sont
contents même là il en se disant son
voile assez mais je parle vraiment je
suis je faudrait que j'aille voir les
matchs des raptors 905 et tout ça parce
que paraît-il il ya vraiment une belle
progression et en même temps il est
tombé à toronto est toronto c'est
superbe et celles qui dorment
aujourd'hui c'est presque le meilleur
endroit où tout voilà ce qui fait ce qui
fonde dans l'anneau benton nebraska en
deux ans ils n'ont pas réussi à le faire
et même si certains on aimait beaucoup
benton on aurait jamais pu penser que il
aurait pu faire ça donc ça c'est super
coureur pour une pour justine pour
julian sa gamme assez courageux qui se
livre moi et mes tests physiques sont
pas bons on m'a sûrement peut-être dit
que j'avais que le tir extérieur alors
ça il n'a peut-être pas améliorée autre
chose on va voir on est quand on n'est
que début décembre la saison c'est
jusqu'à fin mars
il n'a pas voilà était à la draft pour
et à la drogue c'est une après c'est ce
que je me dis de loin j'ai aucune info
sur sa
guest que t'être talus des interviews de
lui des
ligands sorti deux ans sorti deux
défaites contre indiana
où il y donc que c'est un des premiers
matches de la saison je crois c'est le
3e 4e match mais par contre indiana est
ce qu'ils seront n'est pas mal de point
d'ailleurs oui il est énorme c'est le
seul bonhomme et des chemises pas
croyable maintenant bras - est en fait
il y gagne pas parce qu'ils n'arrivent
pas à faire un stop défensif à la fin et
donc lui toujours il est très calme il y
aura regardé du film on va se concentrer
et son coéquipier qu'à côté de lui alors
je crois c'est stephen smith je vais pas
dire de bêtises hossa smith ques estèphe
meschia ça coince antillais qui dit
voilà c'est le leader de l'équipe tout
le monde le respecte on va tous cessé de
supporter mieux
julian et cetera nous voilà très
respecté dans son vestiaire alors qu'il
n'est que troisième année qui dans une
équipe avec pas mal de mecs expérimentés
et d'ailleurs on peut peut-être insisté
là dessus c'est la première fois de sa
vie que ça lui arrive d'être le
go-to-guy de son équipe ç'a toujours été
un un rôle play c'est la première fois
qu'il a qui a les clés d'une attaque en
réalité c'est poche alexander qui tient
la balle depuis deux ans une grosse
recrue et qu'un peu qui est la première
recrue de leur coach comment il
s'appelait mike sanderson plaidant sa
cause d'arkansas qui avait développé pas
mal de joueurs là-bas aussi et
c'est vrai que champagne est beaucoup
plus leader cette année je trouve que
c'est son équipe à lui peut-être pas
dans la création et tout ça mais ça
nicoas assure que son équipe
alors que le taux d'usagé pour l'instant
a pas bougé ce soit mais
intéressant par contre c'est que il l'a
fait baisser son taux de turn over enfin
ceux de balles perdues point de
comparaison intéressant je vais vous
demander on va parler un petit peu de sa
projection draft vous allez prenons tous
me répondent second tour si j'ai bien
j'ai bien évaluer vos évaluations second
tour au mieux alors j'ai peut-être le
sommet des débuts de début second tour
en jeu je peux y penser ok elle à nos
débuts second tour nico pour l'instant
il est 55e hockey et j'ai pas fais un
truc aussi lavaur et
gelée au second tour j'ai une équipe qui
pointe tout nico est ce que est ce qu on
a un scénario idéal pour ses deux
premières années c'est quoi c'est comme
on disait tout à l'heure il devient un
bus pendant l'été ils gagnent un peu de
latéralité tout en ne perdant pas de tir
on voir en accélérant son tir et il est
drafté par les warriors comme ça il peut
passer son temps à trois points et a
tenté de prendre des revanches non je
souhaite pour moi le scénario idéal
c'est une équipe avec
vous allez me dire c'est le cas de
toutes les équipes nba mais non une
équipe avec un très bon développeur
cosplayeurs qui n'est pas du temps
devant dans le bon ordre ouais voilà une
équipe qui vont voir ils vont pas le
lâcher vont continuer à faire bosser
pour qu'il devienne voilà une sorte de
joe crowder du pauvre pour moi le
lej au coders c'est donc le frère de
cheikh rôdeur
tu connais pas jack rogers ben si il
fait il fait des concerts de country
dans le texas 3-2 aux dernières
nouvelles il était 13 heures
donc voilà pour moi le plafond de jeunes
champagne
cissé journeyman nba ses
10e et 11e hommes mais avec un plancher
haut
3 allez je vais aller loin dans mes
scénarios 3 en nba puis après il y
débarque dans une très bonne équipe en
europe pour faire une grosse période ah
voilà ça c'est intéressant aussi
l'udc à bâgé pas unique sans moi
j'aimerais beaucoup le voir en europe où
il peut peut-être se sentir beaucoup
plus à l'aise et que tu auras moins de
le switch pour tous voilà que ça va
devenir compliqué de venir en sorte de
me rotich devenu désuet ce qu'on aura
mirotic a bien fondu eh ouais avec tout
le respect que j'ai pour
ce n'est pas très grand vue qui espagnol
mais bref
est-ce que vous avez des choses à
ajouter des choses qu'on a pas d'eau on
n'a pas parlé qu'on n'a pas abordé sur
julian ciampini sera sur la carrière en
europe seraient d'accord
il fait penser à un jour que j'ai qui
joue à la turk telekom maintenant que je
pensais que qui a un coût qui pourrait
jouer une pièce et aubrey dawkins
l'ancien joueur de michigan ah oui et
youssif
le fils du co la vie c'est vrai tu vois
elle avait été amenée chez un gros match
contre ailleurs exactement rallye et qui
joua türk telekom et que tu vois en
eurocup et voilà que ce genre de joueurs
là je pensais que dawkins pouvait pas
avoir une place en nba finalement il n'a
pas mais
il est très solide et solides de
mémoires une bonne équipe européenne
mais je pense que ça peut ça peut aider
c'est un peu ça va je mets des
conteneurs en plus pour dire une bêtise
donc vas-y fini ta phrase
non mais ça peut aider à revenir en nba
c'est que tu es dir weh complètement et
puis surtout je pense que en fait ce
qu'on dit à chaque fois c'est papa
seront responsables est qu'on n'est pas
très bon jour deux bandits oui
ça c'est clair non mais c'est clair que
julian champagny je pense qu'on en a été
dur aussi pendant 30 minutes mais ça
sera très très probablement joueur
professionnel de basketball et le
scénario idéal j'ai c'est un idéal à
julien de champagne qui drafté par les
bulls comme ça on pourra dire les bulles
de champagne et voilà sur ce jeu wii
joli mais la paire si ça va aller
hugues l'aiment pas trop et il est
supporter des boulistes voilà vous
l'aurez compris mais c'est quand même
toujours au mieux que
c'est qui la pipe que vous aviez drafté
ya deux ans hughes
oui c'est ça alors l'usp appareil c'est
qu'il est abonné à l'habituel parce que
c'est un bon joueur mais il faut juste
pas joué la pâte d'eau et on a eu dans
le style paul type soeur tu as très lent
des pieds al malik ces terrains qui font
du foot ça peut ressembler à ça aussi
pour
le secteur
sont pas ni l'a22 ips heure dans chaque
sens donc ça là dessus on a été dur avec
lui mais effectivement si on parle
jusqu'à exercer saison voix pour dire
oui il ya des jours où il ya des joueurs
et qu'on était joueur nba qui finalement
importe s'intéresser à moins de potasse
par sa capacité tir il a une chance
c'est ça c'est ça absolument c'était
julian champagny le frère de justin
avec lequel on peut faire plein de jeux
de mots plus ou moins inspirés et
c'était notre podcast d'envergure sur
lui vous pouvez retrouver sa fiche sur
envergure pensez vous pouvez vous
abonner à notre chaîne youtube à notre
chaîne twitch notre compte twitter
on essaye d'être à beaucoup d'endroits
et si vous pouvez relayer un travail si
vous voulez mais évidemment et ben ça
nous fait beaucoup de bien et beaucoup
de plaisir également
gros bisous les amis bonne fête bonne
soirée ciao tout le monde